you or someone you know may have been
diagnosed with type 2 diabetes
this video will show you some ways to
help manage it
there are steps you can take that may
help you keep your blood glucose or
sugar within a normal range this may
help you avoid the complications of type
2 diabetes this may be done through a
combination of eating a healthy diet
getting regular exercise
and taking medications as prescribed by
your doctor as necessary
some people may also need to check their
blood sugar as directed by their doctor
eating a healthy diet may help to lower
your blood sugar level you can help do
this by eating a diet with fruits
vegetables and whole grains
have meals and snacks about the same
time every day
carbohydrates are substances your body
uses to make energy eat the right
balance of carbohydrates proteins and
fats
and reduce your intake of high sugar
foods
getting regular exercise even just 30
minutes a day may lower your blood sugar
level and may lead to weight loss talk
to your doctor before starting an
exercise program
you may need to take one or more oral or
injectable diabetic medications to help
lower blood sugar some of these
medications may increase the amount of
insulin your pancreas makes others
reduce insulin resistance in your
skeletal muscles
some medications make certain tissues
more sensitive to insulin
others cause your digestive system to
take in less sugar
some medications let helpful chemicals
in your digestive system
stay active longer these chemicals help
lower your blood sugar level
other medicines help your pancreas
release insulin when your blood sugar is
high
they also slowed down the release of
insulin when your blood sugar is low
and some medications increase the amount
of sugar excreted in your urine
if your diabetes cannot be controlled
with diet exercise and or other
medications your doctor may also
consider insulin insulin that you inject
helps to replace the insulin your body
would normally produce
a health care professional will train
you to inject them just under your skin
you may need to check the level of sugar
in your blood with a glucometer ask your
doctor how often to check
to do this you will prick your finger
with a small needle called a Lancet
then you will place a drop of blood in
the glucometer following the directions
provided with your glucometer based on
your blood sugar level you may need to
adjust your meals physical activity or
medication dose as directed by your
doctor
by treating and controlling your blood
sugar level you may help prevent the
complications from type 2 diabetes
it is important to take your medications
as directed by your doctor do not go off
your medication unless your doctor tells
you to do so tell him or her about any
side effects you may have